In this video, we're going to take a look
at Nanite and virtual shadow maps.
And essentially, we'll be asking why we should use Nanite,
especially when in conjunction with Lumen.
We'll be taking a look at how you actually can use it
and how to set it up, and then
just have a quick overview of what virtual shadow maps are,
what the limitations are, and how they actually work.
So why Nanite?
It's Unreal Engine 5's virtualized geometry system.
It's still this hierarchical system of smaller parts
used in triangles and allows you to have
a lot more geometric complexity with fewer issues.
It allows for a higher visual fidelity
and works really well with Lumen.
Outside of Lumen, the generating of shadow maps
will also take too long on a complicated mesh.
So being used in conjunction with Lumen,
you'll get much better results.
Virtual shadow maps are used for more realistic results.
And instant object count and draw calls
are less of a limitation.
You can have each instance now with millions and millions
of polygons, and you get automatic LODs,
which use a cluster of data.
Importantly, it's more visually
accurate than displacement.
You get fewer shadow artifacts than using
an old system like in Unreal Engine 4's material
displacement.
It's inaccurate, especially with extreme shadowing changes
and light changes.
And the good thing is, again, that Nanite is great for really
high-resolution models, and you keep really good accuracy
in the shadow and through the virtual shadow maps.
So to enable Nanite on a mesh, it's really, really
quite simple.
You can open up the Static Mesh Editor
and tick the Build Nanite option here,
and it will be built automatically for you.
You can also right-click on the asset, go to Nanite,
and enable.
And if you're using Chaos, you
can also change it in the Collections Editor.
So you can have Enable Nanite support right there.
One note, actually, is that virtual textures aren't required
to be used with Nanite, but they are highly recommended,
especially if you're making a large world.
And we'll go into it a little bit later in a second,
but it essentially allows the MIP generation
to be a little bit more performant.
So when it comes to Nanite, you
can change some of the Nanite properties
via the Tools pulldown.
And one important thing as well
is that Nanite doesn't support hollow geometry,
so non-watertight meshes.
And really, it does support it.
It just means that the shadowing from those
will be inaccurate.
So you could use blocking geometry,
like a cube, to go behind that section
to actually get the shadowing that you need.
So let's take a look at virtual shadow maps.
The important thing about virtual shadow maps,
more than anything, is that it significantly
increases the resolution and makes sure that it
matches the Nanite geometry.
And this is different to just normal shadow maps,
which is just essentially a texture projection.
You get plausible soft shadows with really,
it says reasonable here, really nice, actually,
in control of performance costs.
Provides a simple solution that works by default
with limited amounts of adjustment.
And it replaces the use of stationary lights
in many cases and shadowing techniques
with a single unified path of just using those movable lights.
It's really made for Lumen.
It's not intended for really anything else.
So that's something to keep in mind.
Compared to big shadow maps, the things it solves
is essentially shadow maps are just like textures
and can have mismatching sampling rates.
So if you have more screen pixels than shadow pixels,
you'll get aliasing.
As well as more shadow pixels than screen pixels,
you get essentially wasted work.
It's impossible to match these rates perfectly.
And you also get perspective aliasing
due to camera positions.
Now, when it comes to virtual shadow mapping,
they deal with similar issues.
But they handle shadows similarly.
But virtual texturing will essentially
split the texture and mipchain into tiles.
So it only streams the tiles that it needs.
So when I was mentioning earlier
that it is recommended to actually use virtual textures,
this is the main reason why.
When it comes to local lights, you get a 16 by 16K resolution
with eight mips.
Spotlights use a single virtual shadow map.
Point and rectangular lights use six virtual shadow maps.
And that would be one per cubic phase.
You get 2K more than conventional shadow maps.
And it can still run out if you make massive local lights.
But you probably won't be encountering those issues.
When it comes to directional lights,
16K is just nowhere near enough anyways
because they essentially work for the entirety of the world.
So mipmaps are going to cover the same amount of work
but half the resolution.
And we essentially use clipmap levels that are all 16K
but cover double the area.
So the idea is that, depending on the location,
we create snaps of the clipmaps
to make sure that the pages fall on the grid.
And essentially get really nice shadows
for the entirety of the scene
while caching stuff for a lot of fallbacks
and things like that.
So you can see the virtual shadow maps
allow for more precise control.
But let's take a look at what we can do
to actually change the look of those shadows.
So you can use some console variables
to get better resolutions
and better effects at the cost of performance.
You can use some of the commands that you see here
in the console to actually adjust the number of rays.
The fewer the rays, the greater the noise.
But if you set it to zero,
it'll just create a straight up hard shadow.
And you can also change the number of samples
that are used for shadow rays.
And again, the higher the value, the worse performance.
But using values between four and eight
seems to work pretty well.
So the penumbra has limits,
but you can extend those limits again
if you use some of the commands for the console here.
So if you use either of these,
you can start tweaking the values
to essentially get more reasonable-looking shadows
for the performance that you're looking for.
When it comes to visualizing
and actually being able to see
what changes that you're doing are actually doing,
here's some useful ones.
So you've got the shadow mask,
which is the final shadow mask
that's being used for the shading,
the clip map or mip level.
So that's the chosen clip map for directional lights
or mip for local lights.
The virtual page,
so there's the visualization of the page address
and the cache page,
which they're tinted green, essentially,
and uncache-ed areas are tinted red.
Pages where only the static page is cached
will show up as blue.
So that's something to keep in mind.
Again, to get these visualizations,
especially for anything that's actually
used in virtual texturing,
like clip maps and things like that,
or these mips,
you will have to turn on Shader Model 6
or run DirectX 12,
like we mentioned earlier on our Lumen talk.
And that's really it.
After this, we're just gonna load up a project
and just create some lights,
create some glowing objects,
keep things nice and simple
to make sure that we can actually
take a look at things properly.
But yeah, mess around,
see if you can create some for yourself.